identify the most reasonable units to
measure each of the following choices so
the time it takes to bake one pan of
cookies let's see that's usually in the
minutes so I'll go with minutes unless
you're doing some type of slow baking
but I'll say minutes is a is a
reasonable unit here the time it takes
to pour a cup of coffee well that that
might take you at most one or two
seconds so you definitely want to do it
in hours or years if we already used up
minutes and you definitely want to use
minutes either it's only a few seconds
the time it takes to drive from Chicago
to st. Louis
well that's hopefully won't take you
years that'll take you I don't know the
exact distance but it's gonna take you
several hours to do that so I will go
with hours let's do a few more of these
identify the most reasonable units to
measure each of the following choices
below with kilometers meters and
millimeters in a kilometer of course
Killough tells us that's equivalent to a
thousand meters and milli means one
thousandth of a meter another way of
thinking about a meter is a thousand
millimeters and a kilometer is a
thousand meters the length of a ladybug
well the length unless it's some kind of
some kind of monster or ladybug we're
probably thinking in millimeters the
height of an average person so an
average person is multiple meters it's
going to be at least one meter tall but
and in more more likely closer to 2
meters especially your average male
adult male would be right around 2
meters tall so I would go with meters
the length of a marathon so this is a
long distance race we're talking about
here if you're used to thinking in in in
in English and you say US customary
units a marathon is 26 miles a kilometer
isn't quite equal to a mile it's around
1.6 kilometers is equal to a mile but it
also makes sense to measure this in
kilometers you would measure the length
of a marathon and miles or kilometers
you'd measure the height of an average
person if you're using US customary
units you would do it in feet if you're
using metric units you'd do it in meters
the distance between San Francisco and
Los Angeles
once again this is several thousand
kilometers will go with kilometers are
actually San Francisco to Los Angeles is
several hundred kilometers I thought
that said New York to Los Angeles San
Francisco Los Angeles several hundred
kilometers but still you went two
kilometers the length of an average
sized swimming pool well meters seems
like a reasonable measure there your
average pool might be 25 meters or 50
meters or something like that
the thickness of a slice of bread so a
slice of bread if I had it would be it's
definitely a lot thinner than a meter so
I'm gonna go with millimeters and go
with millimeters down here check our
answer we got it right let's do one more
identify the most reasonable units to
measure the weight of each of the
following choices below so see we have
ounces and pounds and just as a reminder
one pound is equal to 16 ounces or an
ounce is equal to 1/16 of a pound so a
couch well that's going to be many many
many pounds probably over a hundred
pounds so we definitely won't put this
in the pounds category a cookie unless
it's a really large cookie it's going to
weigh less than a pound so I I'm
comfortable going it seems reasonable to
go with ounces a television well they
get they're getting lighter every day
but they still weigh a good bit they
still weigh multiple pounds usually
multiple tens of pounds so we'll go with
pounds a cracker and once again unless
we're talking about a really huge
cracker most crackers are very very
light lighter than even a cookie so we
will go with ounces